I'm gonna do the SMP in Blackfoot thank
you Mr Speaker he was the smp's face at
Westminster for half a decade
Ian Blackford was a close Ally of
Scotland's first Minister Nicholas
sturgeon but questions over his
leadership have been mounting just weeks
ago his party denied colleagues were
engineering a coup but now he's gone
Annie denies being sidelined as the
first Minister has asked me to be her
business Ambassador I can't do that and
serve as Westminster leader as well with
the AGM coming up next week it's right
that I signal to the group that I'm
still going to carry on serving as MP
for Roscoe and lacabra servicing my
constituents but making sure I'm working
with the first Minister working with the
party to build the keys and it's right
that the group chooses a new leadership
this was the beginning of the end for
Blackford are you going to give him the
whip back are you going to allow him
back into the park
the SNP
mishandling of harassment complaints
against former smpmp Patrick Grady
created unrest among colleagues caused
upset for the victim
and when I walked into his office I've
got Ian Blackford the leader of my party
that I worked for and I've got the chief
whip of the party I work for and also my
line manager crying in front of me
apologizing
um I I always made to feel guilty in
that situation I felt bad for him in
that situation looking back I know
that's irrational now but at the time um
you know I felt like I had no choice but
to accept the apology the rumbles of
discontent are clear smpmp Joanna Cherry
a Critic of the current leadership
saying she was pleased to hear a
Blackfoot had quit saying it was time
for fresh leadership tolerance of debate
and diverse viewpoints
the SNP portrays a united front a party
plotting a plan towards a second
independence vote a party now in search
of a replacement at its top table Conor
Gillis Sky News